>> Tucker: THERE’S A LOT.
>> YOU’RE WELCOME.
>> Tucker: SEE YOU AGAIN.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ IS A RETIRED AND
IMMINENT PROFESSOR AT HARVARD.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
ALL OF THIS IS COMING OUT AS
WE’RE REPORTING IT AND HARD TO
ASSESS.
BUT I WANT TO GET TO THE CORE
ALLEGATIONS ONCE AGAIN.
SO YOU HEARD CATHERINE HERRIDGE
SAY REPEATEDLY THAT THE SPECIAL
SAY REPEATEDLY THAT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL SAID THAT MICHAEL COHEN
COUNSEL SAID THAT MICHAEL COHEN IS IN CONTACT WITH THE RUSSIANS
IS IN CONTACT WITH THE RUSSIANS
AT VARIOUS POINTS.
HOW WOULD THAT BE CRIMINAL?
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD
THAT BE CRIMINAL, DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, ONLY BE CRIMINAL IF,
FOR EXAMPLE -- THIS IS A
HYPOTHETICAL -- THE CAMPAIGN OR
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR SOMEBODY ON
HIS BEHALF OFFERED PUTIN A
PENTHOUSE APARTMENT AT THE TOP
OF THE TOWER IN EXCHANGE FOR
GETTING A PERMIT TO BUILD THE
TOWER.
THAT WOULD BE ARGUABLY CRIMINAL
UNDER THE FEDERAL CORRUPT
PRACTICES ACT.
SHORT OF THAT, IT’S VERY, VERY
HARD TO SEE THIS.
I THINK WE’RE SEEING A COMING
ATTRACTION TO WHAT THE REPORT
WILL BE.
I THINK THE REPORT WILL SET OUT
A CIRCUMSTANTIAL CASE BASED ON
ALL THE LYING THAT IS TAKING
PLACE, A CIRCUMSTANTIAL CASE FOR
ARGUABLY POLITICAL SINS.
BUT I DON’T SEE ANY CRIMES.
COLLUSION ITSELF IS NOT A CRIME.
USING INFORMATION GIVEN BY
RUSSIA TO WIKILEAKS WOULD NOT BE
A CRIME UNLESS THE CAMPAIGN
PARTICIPATED WITH WIKILEAKS IN
THE HACKING ITSELF.
THERE’S NO EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THAT.
SO WHAT I’M AFRAID IS GOING TO
HAPPEN IS THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL
WHOSE JOB IT IS ONLY TO FIND
CRIMES, NOT SINS, ONLY CRIMES,
WILL BLUR THE LINE BETWEEN
CRIMES AND SINS AND WRITE A
REPORT DESIGNED TO PUT THE
PRESIDENT IN A BAD LIGHT BUT IN
THE END, THEY WON’T BE ABLE TO
FIND ANY SPECIFIC VIOLATIONS OF
FEDERAL CRIMINAL STATUTES UNLESS
THEY STRETCH THESE VAGUE LAWS
LIKE OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
BEYOND ANY RECOGNITION.
>> Tucker: SO IS IT A
PROSECUTOR’S JOB
CONSTITUTIONALLY TO PAINT A
POLITICIAN OR ANYONE IN A "BAD
LIGHT" WITHOUT CHARGING HIM WITH
RELEVANT CRIMES?
THAT’S NOT IN HIS PURVIEW, IS
IT?
>> IT’S WORSE THAN IMPROPER.
IT’S UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THE GRAND JURY HAS A SPECIFIC
FUNCTION.
IT’S SUPPOSED TO ONLY INDICT OR
NOT INDICT.
INDEED, PROSECUTORS GENERALLY
DON’T ISSUE REPORTS FOR THAT
REASON.
THEY ONLY HEAR ONE SIDE OF THE
CASE.
THEY DON’T HEAR THE OTHER SIDE.
THERE’S NO CROSS EXAMINATION OF
WITNESSES.
THAT’S WHY IT’S WRONG FOR
PROSECUTORS TO ISSUE A REPORT.
COMEY SHOULD HAVE NOT HAVE SAID
WE’RE NOT INDICTING HILLARY
CLINTON.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL.
NOW I THINK IT’S WRONG FOR THERE
TO BE A PUBLIC REPORT LAYING OUT
A POLITICAL CASE.
NOW, AT THE VERY LEAST, WHAT HAS
TO HAPPEN IS THE NEW ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS TO, IF HE RECEIVES
THE REPORT, SAY I’M NOT MAKING
IT PUBLIC UNTIL THE OTHER SIDE
HAS HAD A CHANCE TO REBUT IT AND
FILE ITS OWN REPORT.
THEN YOU GET TWO POLITICAL
REPORTS.
ONE FROM EACH SIDE AND THE
PUBLIC CAN JUDGE.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE A DISTORTION OF
WHAT PROSECUTORS OUGHT TO DO.
PROSECUTORS OUGHT TO DO UP AND
DOWN, INDICT, NOT INDICT.
IF YOU HAVE THE EVIDENCE OF
CRIME, INDICT.
OTHERWISE, SHUT UP.
>> Tucker: SO WHEN THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL’S OFFICE RELEASES
DOCUMENTS AS THEY DID TODAY THAT
MAKE CRYPTIC REFERENCES OF
MEETINGS WITH RUSSIA WITHOUT
EXPLAINING WHY THIS IS RELEVANT
OR ILLEGAL, DOES THIS -- IS THIS
OR ILLEGAL, DOES THIS -- IS THISA MANIPULATIVE PUBLIC RELATIONS
A MANIPULATIVE PUBLIC RELATIONS
MOVE RATHER THAN A LEGAL ONE?
>> IT RAISES THE SUSPICION THAT
THE FINAL REPORT WILL ALSO
INCLUDE ALLEGATIONS OF POLITICAL
SIN RATHER THAN SPECIFIC CRIMES.
SIN RATHER THAN SPECIFIC CRIMES.THAT’S JUST NOT THE PROPER ROLE
THAT’S JUST NOT THE PROPER ROLE
OF SPECIAL COUNSEL OR ANY
PROSECUTOR.
I HOPE IT DOESN’T HAPPEN.
I HOPE THAT MUELLER, WHO HAS A
GENERALLY GOOD REPUTATION AS A
PROSECUTOR, WILL REMEMBER THAT
HIS JOB ESSENTIALLY WAS TO
UNCOVER CRIMES THAT OCCURRED
BEFORE HE WAS APPOINTED.
AT THE MOMENT, MOST OF THE
CRIMES HE’S UNCOVERED OCCURRED
AFTER HE WAS APPOINTED.
LYING, LYING TO CONGRESS, LYING
TO PROSECUTORS, AND CRIMES THAT
ARE UNRELATED TO HIS MANDATE.
MANAFORT FOR FINANCIAL CRIMES,
COHEN TAXI CAB CRIMES.
THE ONLY CRIMES HE SEEMS TO HAVE
FOUND RELATED TO RUSSIA ARE BY
RUSSIANS.
THAT WAS NOT PART OF HIS
MANDATE, NUMBER 1.
NUMBER 2, NOBODY IS GOING AFTER
THE RUSSIANS.
THEY WON’T BE SENT TO THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY’RE NOT COMING TO
DISNEYLAND.
THAT’S MOOT.
>> Tucker: ONE FINAL GENERAL
QUESTION.
YOU WATCHED OUR LEGAL SYSTEM AND
PARTICIPATED IN IT FOR DECADES
NOW.
IS IT COMMON FOR PROSECUTORS,
GOOD PEOPLE, PEOPLE OF
INTEGRITY, TO BE CAUGHT UP IN A
ZEALOTRY WHERE THEY BECOME
FOCUSED ON DESTROYING PEOPLE?
>> THAT’S THE PROBLEM WITH
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
YOU COME IN AND THERE’S SOMEBODY
OUT THERE OR PEOPLE OUT THERE
WITH TARGETS ON THEIR BACK.
IN THIS CASE, HE WENT AFTER SO
MANY PEOPLE THAT HAD CLOSE
CONNECTIONS TO THE PRESIDENT IN
AN ATTEMPT TO GET HIM.
DON’T BELIEVE ME.
LISTEN TO JUDGE ELLIS THAT
PRESIDED OVER THE MANAFORT CASE.
HE WAS VERY CRITICAL OF HOW THE
HE WAS VERY CRITICAL OF HOW THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR IS SQUEEZING
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR IS SQUEEZING
PEOPLE.
NOT ONLY IN ORDER TO MAKE THEM
SING BUT IN SOME CASES PEOPLE
ARE COMPOSING BECAUSE THEY THINK
BETTER THE STORY, THE BETTER THE
DEAL.
IT GIVES AN OBJECT LESSON TO
CRIMINAL DEFENSE LAWYERS.
BE CAREFUL WHEN YOU MAKE A DEAL.
WHEN YOU MAKE A DEAL WITH THE
PROSECUTORS, THEY CAN COME BACK
AND HURT YOU.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED TO COHEN.
HE MADE A DEAL.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL SAID HE’S
COOPERATED.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY IN NEW YORK
SAYS HE OUGHT TO GET SUBSTANTIAL
JAIL TIME.
THAT’S WHY IN 53 YEARS OF
PRACTICING LAW, I HAVE VERY,
VERY RARELY MADE DEALS OR PLEAS
WITH PROSECUTORS BECAUSE I
BASICALLY DON’T TRUST THEM.
I DON’T TRUST THE SYSTEM.
THE SYSTEM TODAY IS SO SKEWED IN
FAVOR OF PROSECUTORS AND AGAINST
DEFENDANTS.
>> Tucker: WE MAY LOSE
PERSPECTIVE HERE.
I WANT TO REMIND VIEWERS, THAT
YOU’RE NOT A TRUMP VOTER OR A
FIGURE ON THE RIGHT.
YOU’RE DEFENDING WHAT YOU THINK
IS OUR TRADITION OF LAW.
>> I’VE BEEN SAYING THE SAME
THING FOR 55 YEARS.
SAYING THE SAME THING FOR 55
YEARS.
I EXPRESSED THE SAME CRITICISM
OF PROSECUTORS, WHETHER THEY GO